as others rebuild and recover America is
sliding backwards coronavirus has once
again on the rise cases increasing in 26
states and now the top scientists
fighting the pandemic says the country
is clearly headed in the wrong direction
we can't just focus on those areas that
are having the surge it puts the entire
country at risk we are now having 40
plus thousand new cases a day I would
not be surprised if we go up to a
hundred thousand a day if this does not
turn around and so I am very concerned
but public and political will is
everything and listen to what he's up
against we shouldn't presume that a
group of experts somehow knows what's
best for everyone
states have pursued their own plans here
in Florida they're hurriedly rewriting
them restaurants and bars rolling back
reopening John Delgado has been at the
sharp end of the virus from the start
he's a frontline staffer for a food bank
he's been sleeping in a tent in his
garden for months to avoid infecting his
wife mother-in-law three sons and
grandson inside because of how the surge
came and all this it's frustrating for
me because I want this to be able so I
can go permanently inside just stay
there and hug my family my kids and all
but as infor I don't think it's a waste
what I'm doing because the bottom line
is protecting my family regardless of
what decisions made by our government
officials you've been living in this
tent just by your home for more than two
months and then you see these young
people in the bars the restaurants
they're not wearing masks they're not
social distancing well I saw that I was
I just put my head down and I just said
you know what this is gonna get worse
this is gonna get worse
people are gonna a lot of more people
are gonna die the virus is gonna keep
spreading and the hearts we're gonna get
full
and you know how I know that's happening
because our food lines when I first
started miles towards two months of
something the lines are like getting
smaller getting more control look at it
now miles again starting all over giving
the lines
do you feel angry disappointed I thought
we knew better he is bearing the burden
of a crisis out of control exposing
cracks and every level of leadership